in the end it's it's the experience the
experience ient where real
transformation need to happen it can
only happen because we are shaped by our
lives experiences all the time rather
than if he experienced traumatic
experiences pear shape or that if he
experienced wonderful meaningful
experience for us we will also change by
that so with wave paths we took that and
we realized that if experience is the
foundation for personal change personal
transformation we can work and we need
to work with what we call the Masters of
experience a therapist the artists are
the architects the designers and unify
that and provide the experiences that
that are heating and are changing boom
what's up everyone welcome to simulation
I'm your host down sake on we are still
unconscious as hackings awakened future
summit we are now going to be speaking
to mendel kala hello thank you so much
for coming on the show you're welcome
really appreciate it I'm very excited to
talk to you mendel is the founder and
CEO of wave paths you can find them wave
pass dotnet they merge immersive media
with advances in intelligent
technologies and psychedelic science to
improve global well-being alright
who are you what do you represent Who am
I
big question I studied neuroscience with
a real interest in scientific therapy or
more generally speaking more essentially
an interest in mental health care and
the question what how can we change
people how can we facilitate positive
change and looking at the sonnet of
therapy I realized there's a really
interesting new paradigm here that is
emerging so as a neuroscientist I
studied that and looking into the wave
cycle of therapies being practiced I
realized the important role that music
is playing in at modality so I studied
the interaction between cyclic therapy
or cyclic the program cyclic therapy and
music to understand what's going on and
he added that we could publish several
articles and eventually to found ways
that as well as a company afterwards
right now and have you been in London
the whole time doing this yeah I
actually moved the woman to do that from
where from Holland from Holland okay
cool
so then he started studying neuroscience
in Holland or in uniting I started
studying actually started off as a
biologist first then I pivoted to
neuroscience in Holland and I did an
internship my final internship I'm a
Master degree in London for eight months
that's where I met Robin card Harris and
David knot and that eventually led me to
do an RA with them a research
assistantship a PhD and nystagmus a post
up for a while and then pivot it away
from academia eventually as well and
then so teach us about what the studies
were initially in neuroscience sure so
we we basically did two things I would
say one is looking at the interaction
between the drug and in music um a
neuronal level so how do the psychic
drug interact with the music and what
kind of changes in brain activity brain
connectivity information exchange do we
see when they are provided together and
how does that relate to these changes in
emotionality or a mental imagery that
people report in an interaction what are
the brain mechanisms at play so to speak
but I've always been working on and
these questions from different angles
different disciplines if you wish if you
look at my bookshelf you see a lot of
psychotherapy books for example that's
really where my kind of key interest is
so with these studies who also looked at
phenomenology the the richness of the
experience in a patient population that
I was receiving psilocybin to be treated
for their depression and now there's not
a music playlist for that
and we look at how the music was
experienced and how we may improve the
way we work with music to improve the
experience of the patients and thereby
enhance the therapy articles for them as
well
this seems so synergistic with what East
Forest is doing with his newest album
yeah and also what synthesis is doing
what their Center right second hole into
it
it's just like your research interesting
so how the neural architecture is
impacted by both the use of psilocybin
as well as music yeah that's correct
okay and what were your findings hmm we
looked at mental imagery in a first
study and we found that in the
interaction between in this case LSD and
music we saw an enhanced information
flow from an area specializing personal
memories towards the visual cortex
interesting you need to understand that
brains don't only specialize not only
regions that are specialized but these
are networks that interact with each
other and without changes in the way
that information is being exchanged
between those regions and in degree to
which that happened correlated with the
degree to which people reported more
vivid mental images and/or personal
memories even and then we also looked at
the different acoustic properties that
make up music right music is not mere
sound music is structured sound in time
it has tonalities as rhythm it has all
sorts of acoustic qualities that change
in time so we looked at these different
acoustic properties and we found that
under LSD we saw significant changes in
language areas interesting enough
enhance to the temper the tone color in
the music and in the degree to which
have happened correlated with emotions
associated peak experience or most of
wonder and awe for example so that was
quite interesting and made us like
typical for science asked many more
questions yes in the clinical study with
our patient population we found an
interesting polarity I would say some
people responded really well to the
music and some not and they're
interesting truths to be found when
looking at both stories so one thing
that they found for example is that in
the experience of the music some people
described that music was able to carry
them on this journey inside of
themselves they experienced enhance
emotionality and imagery
and when they were able to really
surrender to the experience they
described it as a journey I said they
were transported on this this this this
this this adventure of discovery which
is in essence the discovery of aspects
of oneself right it's a journey inside
that's also correlated with the attitude
of openness to the music and in the
creative which people reported a sense
of union between themselves and a music
or sense of Harmony now that was on one
side and the other side you had people
who described the music as feeling very
dissonant and out of tune whether in the
experience and these individuals didn't
want the music to be there I mean
rejecting in music now people on will
reported this resonance with the music
these were also inevitable stats and
reported the show the stories
improvement so weeks after the storm
interruption in the pression afterwards
people who didn't have that experience
the music these are the individuals to
in didn't show these improvements in
their in their injuries and the house
afterwards so the more resonant the
experiences with them the decrease in
depression getters yeah no there's a
caveat there because the small study
just 20 patients we looked at yes but
when I delved into music therapy
research I came across something called
the ISO principle and this is a
well-established concept in music
therapy the ISO principle means matching
your emotional state with music so have
having music convey a similar emotional
state that's a big you are currently
experiencing and using that as a
starting point for other therapeutic
work with music and so finally of
convergence we made me confident there
something at play here and that's what
we're currently expanding on as well I
love it I love it okay so the there's
also a a specific potentially music
therapy that resonates most deeply with
each individual that then can be tuned
to their life that can then help them
get through some of the most difficult
moments of their life yeah and then to
be able to assist that music therapy
with potentially psychedelics
and see how people can transform through
those experiences this is your research
this is what you care about okay
and it's really interesting thinking
about all the applications like you
listed to take someone that may feel
depressed and then have them feel like
they're transformed afterward and that
they these deep feelings of unity you
like how you explained on the the
processing of especially something that
to become more visual a personal memory
I things like this okay let's jump into
your move to London to pursue wave paths
mm-hmm okay so how long ago was this
founded what is wave path it was founded
about a year ago okay and then the
mission of wave that's is to make
transformative experiences with music
and other immersive media more widely
available one outcome of the research
and the cyclic their appearances in
general is if you look at how
psychotherapy is currently practiced I
sometimes conceptualize it as a for
music therapy but it's a drug enhance
form of music therapy so then the
question is what is so different about
the experience of music in that
psychedelic state and could be maybe
access that without a drug as well not
not because we don't want psychedelic
therapy to be there but how can we help
prepare people for these experiences how
can we help people in their greatest
experience afterwards and also can we
find a way of engaging with ourselves
that not always and the monsters that
take this particular compounds and I
believe there's a real opportunity for
music to feel that for its sisters that
people have to engage with their inner
worlds in meaningful constructive ways
there's a lot more to say about music
but the emerging almost everyone has
some relationship with music it's
ancient music is one of the most ancient
human inventions they're one of the most
ancient technologically invented so we
music has come to play many different
roles in our society it can be a social
glue it can be an aid to relax it can be
entertaining it can be fun it can be
beautiful but some
being more profound can happen when you
listen so deeply to music that in
essence you're deeply listen to yourself
the gold as deep listening and so
there's this question that we are asking
with wave that says can we invite people
to listen to music in such way that
their relationship with music becomes so
intimate that music can become their
friend a companion a healer a therapist
that people have access to at any more
any moment in their lives that is the
the essence of what we're trying to do
and we are in essence working to develop
a new approach to well-being that
ignites our innate capacity to heal
through music and other intelligent
technologies you mentioned the word
transformation right and depression
really important question there is what
is transformation in essence like what
we're talking about and transformation
doesn't mean per definition that if
somebody is depressed that that will be
transformed into some beautiful
wonderful peak experience there may be
some really painful emotions and
memories that need to be processed first
years and often if not always healing
involves reconnecting these parts of
ourselves that we don't really wish to
be connected with because they can be
frightening or overwhelming or painful
but that's a very real healing happens
so it's not that if psychotherapy
anyways that's you only play music that
has these wonderful positive emotional
soundscapes do it sometimes the work
needs to happen by actually allowing
difficult emotions to surface yeah yeah
ok so that love I love the the music is
such an ancient technology and the way
that it can be fully actualized in its
fullest potential to be a friend healer
all these words he used with humans is
so beautiful and we've it seems like
we're only still scratching the surface
of musics potential and a Masonic all
this crazy stuff that's coming so ok so
drop us into what this is like right now
because it's kind of like the
commercialized application of your reach
are also the democratized application of
your research right so is so is so am i
coming in physically to the wave paths
Center am I able to just make it
download and play at home yeah how does
it work we're doing both we're
developing mobile technologies mobile
tools that allow this approach to be
widely available but there's a real
challenge with trying to encapsulate
this process into an app for example you
not have control over the ritual the
attention that the process really
deserves and needs for those effects to
take place most people don't have a good
enough sound system at home as well so
all these things we have much more
control over when we have a physical
space on top of that I believe that the
current mental health crisis we are
witnessing won't be solved by another
digital technology it will be found the
solution will be found within human
communities coming together in real
lived experiences hmm so what we
interview with our way that spaces is or
for our technology which is an adaptive
generative music system so it's music
that is generating music through a
computational system adapted to where
you are in this moment emotionally
immature therapeutic intentions so the
music needs you where you are and this
is based on what we just described with
residents we try to enhance this sense
of residence with the music how do you
know where the person is and how to tune
the music yeah yeah
nano inputs by a body user at this at
this situation and on top of that we
work with some biosensors so we combine
both to provide this achievement for the
music
so they do they were eg or what are they
not what they do we we have a multimodal
vision there at this moment what we did
in our space we work with a radar sensor
operator I'm built in a bowl you don't
even see it yes it emits high frequency
sound and it's able to track movement in
a micro millimeter range and we trained
it to measure breathing and body
movements and then what it does is in
this in this space we imagine and the
Sonics we implement
sound system called analyzer logistics
sound system 22 speakers a drinks on air
side a drinks above you and four
speakers on the ceiling itself and the
music is is generated and response to
your by physiology and a specialization
of the music is informed by your
breathing pattern the depth of your
breath the frequency of your breath so
the space that free breathes with you
with the music and it's not in a subtle
way we don't want it to be kamiki but
all these are experiments in our effort
to enhance this degree of resonance and
the immersive sound technology allows
you to forget that you're in a space yes
you lie on a charity of a new mosque and
the only thing that's there is your mind
and the music and all the interactions
were do you mind enemies got a curse in
there so a miniature I have I mask on
and you have a somewhat of an a Masonic
system it's a lot of speakers yes as and
and this three submission exits
analyzers yeah exactly yeah it's a it's
a similar 3d technology 3d technology
with sound and then you have this radar
technology that's able to at a
millimeter micrometer at a micro
millimeter yeah Wow okay be able be able
to what everybody moves a sense my heart
the best yeah your your breathing my
breathing and so then if my breathing is
maybe shallowing or it's deepening
whichever you're changing the music
adapting it to my breath and how I'm
kind of replying to it and your Amin to
make these experiences as as healing and
transformative for people as possible
and right now they have to come in with
there's also is they're also visual no
there's not because there is yeah that's
a good question so what I want to
emphasize is that this experience this
introspected experience the music with
this technology is embedded within a
human relationship and all of that is
embedded within a ritual so the current
space that we have in London before you
enter this music space you enter on the
Colo light space and it's literally a
space to be
nothing that distracts you you're just
present in this in this world of color
basically and you meet a guy wears a
trained psychotherapist and you already
are invited before hands in a
preparation
email to reflect on your intention in
the experience I have certain tools that
allow you to figure out what's present
what's alive in you in this moment and
how you would we're going to work with
that then you meet your psychotherapist
guide in this light space and you spend
around 20 minutes exploring your
intention then you go to the music space
at the second room and the cards go to
an induction and meditation that helps
you to be and feel more safe and open to
the music then you go on its journey
alone and by yourself
afterwards you return to the light space
you're you are spending another twenty
minutes or so with your card integrating
and processing the experience before you
then and then go home again
Oh wonderful yeah you're the whole the
pre and post yeah well yeah well done as
well okay so in terms of the wave paths
being able to get out as a digital
download yes you said that it's
difficult because how do you know about
how the person feels and how do you make
sure that they've got a quick sound
system that's high quality yeah yeah so
were you guys at with taking it to the
democratize yeah we are we are kind of
reconsidering our strategy with that a
lot of the moments because from a
business perspective of course this app
could be an easy way to scale up our
business relatively quickly also from a
therapeutic standpoint it could be a way
to democratize this experience more
widely what we did for now is we are
only releasing the app that we have
right now the people who visited our
space there's almost like an initiation
you know this stays experienced those
guests get the app afterwards to
continue to practice at home but you are
considering to release a version of this
app by the end of the year that's for
currently working and that app will also
have these different contexts in which
you can engage with the music different
types of meditations different types of
inductions guidelines and ways to
process the experience afterwards as
well
you could potentially get quite good at
targeting specific so ailments emotional
ailments yeah bad that could be
interesting yeah that's that's division
we've right now focus on well-being as a
broad construct and you don't focus
right now on severe mental health
conditions yeah also because we don't
want to make any medical claims you
don't really have them this is an
experimental technology right but we
have that ambition for sure and the
partner and we offer Arthur can watch us
to institutions for example people don't
sonic therapy research in Hollands with
and they may at the moment excellent
they will have a prototype of our app
the support their patients going through
their therapy sessions treating severe
PTSD with excellent so you are already
doing the partnerships with maps and
that type of wonderful wonderful and
then okay so let's go let's go to the
again to what what could potentially
come from this you're looking at all of
the different styles of exploration with
transformation of well-being there's
potential also work with some neuro
degeneration then could you could offset
maybe there's also work with neural
augmentation you could come in and get a
potentially and you similar to what
we're doing with East Forest here in the
in the morning yes come in you get the
awakening experience and then you go on
the rest of it yeah yeah day so yeah so
what about on the augmenting side and
also on the degeneration side have you
thought about have you had a have
thoughts about that
yeah I thought thoughts about that I
mean yes there are some really
fascinating research out there that
shows that certain aspects of sounds can
be useful for treating Parkinson's
symptoms for example and dementia people
with dementia respond to many powerful
to music and it's becoming more and more
recognized as a as a tool to support
these individuals and the list goes on I
am we are with wave paths not per
definition interested in sound itself
but more in music and that's because
with music deep silence for richness and
that is essential for such a therapeutic
work so we're not particularly
interested in sound therapy we we
actually don't like that terrible though
some journalists started
use it to describe what we do because
the healing doesn't happen in the sound
that happens in your engagement your
conscious engagement with the experience
that is unfolding it's a dynamic process
so be very much inspired by
psychotherapy two concepts here where it
is you don't lie there and have a
passive experience of sound that does
some healing although some of that may
be true we believe that much more
interesting and important work can be
done in that richness of the north or of
the minds that you can work with in
these in these experiences beautiful
dynamical interplay between the human
and the music therapy is actually
occurring all the way there protein
music as a language but it's a nonverbal
language it conveys emotions and
sensations and images right and it can
do so without activating the intellect
in fact it does so by bypassing the
intellect and that's why I believe it
has such therapeutic potential yeah
that's that's where talk therapy can run
against its limitations because you keep
engaging with talking and analyzing if
if you're not carefully contextualizing
it's your problems and in the end it's
it's the experience the experience of
science where real transformation need
to happen it can only happen because we
are shaped by our lives experiences all
the time
I don't if he experienced traumatic
experiences pear shape or that if we
experience wonderful meaningful
experience for us we also change by that
so with wave paths we took that and we
realized that if experience is the
foundation for personal change personal
transformation we can work and we need
to work with what we call the Masters of
experience the therapist the artists the
architects the designers and unify that
and provide the experiences that that
are heating and are changing is there a
specific style of music that bypasses
this gatekeeper and gets to this
subconscious design
is there something that specific that
does it most of them yeah music is our
emotional response to music is really
combination of innate capacities in
innate tendencies to respond to sound
and music in certain ways that are based
on our evolutionary heritage and I would
argue to much larger degree our
upbringing of our culture or what I call
a musical personality that that we be
acquired in time so I may burst in tears
by this song but you may not feel
anything mm-hmm
right so but then at the same time there
are certain interesting communalities
there as well play both in in this
therapeutic work that's when we believe
that you need to meet the person where
he or she is in this moment and that
includes taking into account the music
personality of the individual not
because you want to give the initial
experience that he or she likes it's not
about liking it's not about pleasure
it's about finding ways to engage the
individual it's it's working with the
ego to some degree as well rather than
trying to fight it interesting so it's a
it's a personalized experience based on
what what both the ancestral lineage of
that of that human plus what they
themselves have absorbed a stimuli
throughout their life to gain that
personal touch on what they find most
profound and the music and then the
responsibility on the end of someone
like wave paths to be able to figure out
what that is for that that's available
yeah interesting so then so it
potentially is some sort of a process
maybe then through the democratization
where there could be a feedback
mechanism for you to learn about the
person's individual but it's exactly
what we're doing yeah that's what we're
doing so we to build a picture to our
research we have some clues about
different categories of therapeutic
functions of music but it's only based
on a very limited sample size so rather
than trying to mold people into these
different categories
we allow people to score and rate their
musical experiences so in time we have a
fully data data derived what I'm up
categorization of those different
experiences and then in doing that we
can become more more precise and
actually prescribing music as a medicine
through each individual yes exactly yes
yes yes very beautiful okay I want to do
a couple other thoughts on the way here
what is the the percentage of time that
you think that there's going to be
people that are experiencing wave paths
without psychedelics versus with
psychedelics as psychotherapy hmm oh
that's an interesting question it was
founded with the idea to support ocular
therapy but then realizing the
therapeutic potential of music and
realizing that there are all of those
people out there that don't have access
to psychotherapy we want to offer music
as psychedelic therapy music as of
psychedelic experience music as a micro
reading experience so what I hope is
exceeded all of that will happen that
people who are seeking psychedelic
medicines either because they're
suffering deeply from depression or PTC
or you name it in a clinic or whether
people seek these for their own personal
development that had access to these
tools to support them in the best way as
possible but at the same time there is
it's not all about the sonicator drug
experience right you have the apart from
the preparation you have homework to do
afterwards and like I mentioned earlier
on there is I feel when I speak with
people it will avoid their to be filled
how can I work with what happened in the
cyclic experience how can I continue to
engage with that and I think with the
approach we're developing we're offering
a very very safe effective and engaging
way to do that and through music in
addition to that I also think that
songket of therapy won't be for everyone
and it could be other approaches that
are also very powerful that maybe not as
in disruptive as a psychic experience
can be and music and our approach and
other approaches could could play a role
in that as well so my hope is really
that that that both both women and time
and what's the ideal future where is it
ambisonics 360 degrees plus visual plus
the feedback loop to the personalized me
taste in music and visuals is that kind
of the ideal future we will see you know
what a data tells us so right now we run
four different scientific research
projects with our current space with our
approach including Universal study and
that's our our intention is to keep
refining our approach fully empirically
keep challenging our assumptions and
then in time you'll find something
that's that that really works with the
music and the sound system yes that's
definitely something we will keep
replicating and keep exploring the role
of light is something that we actually
just assure about it's it's more of an
experiment as well we are researching
the light art that we work with for
example optogenetics is a very
interesting field yeah opto genetics
yeah yeah mmm neuromodulation through
light yeah right but that happens with
genetic modifications in animals adopted
genetics like optogenetics is method
where you to my view and generally
modify a gene making it responsive to
lights and then you flicker light to do
the nervous all to make it fire or make
a receptor change the shape or you name
it and there's potentially some
interplay with what the with if if you
you know remove though the eye cover and
then you have the visual stimulation
yeah insurance the musical stimulation
we did it completely apart from genetic
modifications there's something in
lights right that is as music something
we respond to very very powerfully
absolutely and that's what we notice in
our space where this this light space
and people respond to it really you know
really profoundly and it's
it's something again we don't really
understand yet but it's something we are
experimenting as part of our larger
mission to ask ourselves how can we
engage the census not only music but
also light and smell and touch those
interactions to provide a unified
framework to facilitate these
transformative experiences oh that's
excellent Oh lavender
sprays and maybe there's so many cool
things touch the touch as through the
process as well that's great that's
great and then also just all the
testimonials all the people afterward
that that tell you how important it was
that they went through your experience
and what the transformation they had was
and being able to yeah maybe have some
EEG or some sort of a way to have the
bio signals captured before and after
that I hate the thing this has been very
interesting let's um let's do a couple
quick questions on the way out do you
think we're in a simulation do I think
very an assimilation oh my god it's a
field I haven't given it's an idea I
haven't given that much thought to I
know that our serious physics we make an
argument for it do I feel like I'm in a
simulation I don't but it could be very
effective simulation but do I believe
we're in a simulation I don't know but
it's an entertaining and interesting
philosophical question for sure and then
what do you think's the most beautiful
thing in the world what I think is the
most beautiful thing involved huh
a few things come to mind
nature or human beings being honest with
each other and authentic with each other
why do you say that because that's
really beautiful and important and
missing a lot in our society at the
moment yeah I think that's where a lot
of this this thirst for these approaches
comes from is rather than having created
a society where technology is being used
to remove suffering and bring us closer
together we have created some kind of
mega machine that is there to track our
data Taylor advertisements to us make us
more efficient at work replace ourselves
at work more and more and I think a lot
of the fears in society are are based on
that lack of increasing sense of
disconnection from other people from
meaning existential meaning all those
things so it's beautiful when people are
able to find that and when you feel let
them in you're part of that thank you so
much for joining us on the show of
teaching us about all your work you're
worried about very fascinating thank you
thank you
thank you huge thank you to everyone for
tuning in we greatly appreciate it we
would love to hear your thoughts in the
comments below on the episode go and
talk more to your friends your family or
coworkers people online on social media
about this powerful process of music and
the transfer transformational potential
that it has check out wave paths net the
link is in the bio below also the rest
of Mendel's links and go and support
consciousness hacking there links are
below support simulation our links are
below the organizations entrepreneurs
artists around the world that you
believe and support them and go and
build the future everyone manifest your
dreams into the world thank you so much
for tuning in and we will see you soon
peace